this is the Aedes aegypti mosquito it's
the main mosquito that carries Zika
developing a Zika vaccine could take
years
so right now officials only tool is to
control mosquitoes so here's the
situation the Zika virus was first
identified in Uganda in 1947 and was
thought to cause only relatively mild
flu-like symptoms in May 2015
Zika appeared in Brazil by November
Brazil had seen a 20-fold increase in
babies born with abnormally small heads
a birth defect called microcephaly
months later the Centers for Disease
Control confirms Zika was the cause
some countries have even taken the
unusual step of telling women to put up
plans for pregnancy the spread of Zika
from Brazil to other countries and
territories in the Americas has been
rapid in July officials identified more
likely the first cases of local
mosquito-borne Zika transmission in the
continental US so had a Zika spread the
Aedes transmit Zika by biting someone
who has the virus and then biting
another human the virus then moves to
new areas when mosquitoes hitch a ride
on travelers or cargo
then when patients infected in one place
go to a new territory and are bitten by
mosquitoes there scientists have also
confirmed that it can be transmitted
through sexual contact only about one in
five people infected shows symptoms for
those who do get sick the illness isn't
usually severe and lasts about a week
some zika-affected countries are also
seen rising cases of guillain-barre
syndrome a nerve disorder that can cause
paralysis now here's the argument right
now the main way to stop signa is by
using traditional methods to control
mosquitoes another strategy that's
currently being tested is genetically
modified bugs the Brazilian government
has expanded a pilot program that
releases male mosquitoes that have been
modified so that when they breed with
wild females the offspring die early
studies have shown high success rates
but opponents fear unknown consequences
the technology is also with engines as
more people travel there's a higher
chance of mosquito-borne diseases like
Zika spreading to new places ultimately
authorities will need better weapons
against bugs